ce geste c'est devenu une habitude pour
florent prendre le train déplier son
vélo électrique une routine installé
depuis une semaine
comme une cinquantaine de participants
il s'est lancé dans le défi trois
semaines sans voiture j'adopte la
multimodalité
donc c'est à dire que je prends mon je
prends mon vélo de chez moi jusqu'à la
gare montparnasse
ensuite je prends un chemin le ter qui
arrive à la gare de versailles chantiers
ici et ensuite je réutilise ce vélo donc
qui est électrique pour faire les 8
derniers kilomètres qui me sépare de mon
lieu de travail donc un transport je
mettais à peu près une heure 18h15 en
voiture une heure vingt à peu près par
par trajet donc fois dessus aujourd'hui
là avec le vélo train vélo je mets à peu
près 55 1920 de temps est une source de
pollution en moins
le vélo électrique permet aussi de moins
se fatiguer il est prêté par
l'association we move partenaires de
l'opération
les coaches reste en contact avec les
candidats pour se soutenir et régler les
différents problèmes rencontrés malgré
un souci de crevaisons et une panne
florent reste convaincu j'hésitais déjà
avant le défi je me posais la question
est là le fait d'en avoir un en prêt
pendant trois semaines a fini de me
convaincre et ça va être mes futurs
investissements
dès que le porte-monnaie le permet pour
ce type de modèle il faudra compter dans
les 800 euros certains peuvent aller
jusqu'à 2000 la mairie de paris
organisatrice du défi offre une
subvention pour les acheteurs